effectivement nous sommes de retour sur
la terrasse de la Rhodia a Besançon pour
une édition spéciale de la voie et libre
un premier débat consacré aux élections
régionales de décembre prochain en
présence de cinq candidats déclarés
Marie guide Dufay pour le PS Cécile
Prud'homme pour Europe Écologie Les
Verts Alain joyeux pour l'UMP Christophe
guildler pour le modèle et Maxime
Thibault pour debout la France François
Sauvade et hudaïier Sophie Montel FN ont
refusé notre invitation alors Mesdames
Messieurs l'un ou l'une d'entre vous
sera peut-être à la fin de l'année à la
tête d'une collectivité avec plus d'un
milliards 300 millions d'euros de budget
gérant 4000 agents environ vous nous
avez présenté depuis 11 heures
quelques-uns de vos projets pour cette
future grande région mais vous ne vous
nous avez pas dit forcément comment vous
alliez les financer on voulait savoir
quelle recette sur quelle recette vous
comptiez faut-il augmenter la fiscalité
faut-il faire des économies qu'elles
sont les sources les ressources dont
vous disposerez on commence avec vous
Alain Joyandet si vous voulez un
milliard 300 millions c'est 800 millions
en gros pour la Bourgogne 500 millions
pour pour la Franche-Comté quelques
engagements premièrement aucune
augmentation de la fiscalité c'est que
les régions n'ont pas beaucoup
d'autonomie fiscale mais quand même il y
a la question des cartes grises qu'il
faudra trancher 15 euros de moins le
cheval administratif en Franche-Comté
par rapport à la Bourgogne j'ai entendu
dire que les socialistes avaient trouvé
une solution facile c'était de mettre
les Francs comptoirs au niveau de la
Bourgogne et que quelque part ça faisait
17 à 18 millions d'euros de prélèvements
supplémentaires solutions de facilité
qu'évidemment je refuse donc un
engagement fort celui de la fiscalité
deuxième engagement fort celui des
économies je souhaite pouvoir faire 2%
d'économies sur les budgets de
fonctionnement c'est tout à fait
possible sur le milliard 300 millions si
on enlève les investissements parce
qu'évidemment je ne souhaite pas
diminuer l'investissement toute ma
politique sera baisser les coûts de
fonctionnement trouver 2 % sur les
budgets de fonctionnement on peut le
faire dans n'importe quelle collectivité
on sort une somme importante pardon
moins d'agents mais bien sûr qu'il y
aura moins d'agent il faut avoir le
courage de le dire il y aura moins
d'argent
mais bien sûr allons-y pas dans les
domaines d'ailleurs ce sont pas
forcément les agents pardonnez-moi de le
dire de du bas de l'échelle
administrative mais aujourd'hui vous
avez toutes les toutes les directions en
double entre les deux régions il y a
donc tout partout deux directeurs par
exemple et dessous directeur par exemple
faudra des mouvements il faudra réformer
il faudra fusionner un certain nombre de
services importants chaque personnel
doit pouvoir rester à Besançon et à
Dijon dans son travail actuel à
l'exception des cadres qui devront
bouger mais en plus nous avons
véritablement la possibilité de faire
des économies sur le fonctionnement en
général de consacrer ça à
l'investissement et à l'emploi et
surtout au financement de l'emploi des
jeunes merci de vos réponses bref parce
que il nous reste très peu d'émissions
Christophe grüller vous adhérez
pas question d'augmenter les impôts en
face de crise
qu'il a traitées c'est c'est un vrai
problème et on va revoir aussi à cause
de cette éloignement des régions du
peuple peut-être même un besoin de
déconcentration c'est à dire finalement
d'une représentation de la région par
des fonctionnaires au plus près des gens
et ça il va falloir y réfléchir et ça
n'a pas été vu dans les lois
Cécile Prudhomme oui nous on pense qu'il
faut investir sur les fonds énergétiques
et pour avoir des retours comme ça se
fait déjà
on pense qu'il faut investir dans des
fonds dans des fonds énergétiques pour
avoir des retours par exemple en
Franche-Comté c'est fait et sur la on a
investi sur la Compagnie nationale du
Rhône et à l'heure actuelle ça en fait
rentrer un million d'euros par an et si
on fait pareil sur le soleil sur
l'éolien c'est une source de revenus qui
dépend pas ni des dotations de l'État ni
de l'imposition faut-il enfin ce qu'il
faut tailler dans le gras comme nous
disent les trois candidats que vous avez
en face en face de vous on n'a jamais
dit qu'il faut oh non on n'a jamais dit
qu'il fallait tailler dans le gras
il y a des sources d'économies
2% d'économie 2% d'économie sur les
services en fonctionnement ça représente
plus de 20 millions d'euros par an
c'était le c'était un début de la
Réforme d'ailleurs mais bien sûr l'UMP
semblait en douter de ces économies
justement c'est ça fait partie des
engagements nationaux de tous les
candidats US la question s'adresse en
tout cas nous on pense pas qu'il faut
tailler dans le grain au niveau des
employés mais faire d'autres choix et on
préfère préserver les emplois dans la
dans la fonction publique des deux
régions et par exemple je leur dis
arrêtez de financer l'aéroport de
doltawocking financière mais non mais
ils sont titulaires
il faut quand même le dire ils sont
titulaires justement à part les
contractuels bien sûr mais il y a quand
même des fonctionnaires
un chiffre abandonné la parole à Mary
guide du fait les dépenses de
fonctionnement ont été diminués dans les
budgets primitifs 2015 dans les deux
régions pour un total de 16 millions
d'euros
ce qui confirme ce qui confirme bien les
filles ce qui confirme bien les chiffres
que je viens de vous donner il faut
continuer et je peux vous dire que pour
la Franche-Comté c'est extrêmement dur
effectivement de trouver ces économies
parce que je le redis la Cour des
comptes a salué notre effort de gestion
en disant que nous n'avions pas
saupoudrer effectivement nos
financements nous les avions concentré
sur nos compétences fondamentales et
donc effectivement c'est très compliqué
de trouver des économies parce que quand
j'entends dire il faut faire des
économies sur le fonctionnement le
fonctionnement c'est les trains moi je
veux pas moins de train les fonctions le
fonctionnement c'est les formations les
stages l'apprentissage donc il faut
c'est la communication alors à propos
des lycées nous avons mis en place une
politique de rationalisation des
bâtiments à la faveur de la chute
démographique et cela va nous faire est
en train de nous faire faire des
économies et je donne un seul exemple
pour cette année nous avons gagné un
million en poussant les lycées à faire
une commande groupée pour leurs achats
de gaz donc il faut arriver à trouver
des systèmes de ce type là c'est le
mauvais économie
de fermer les lycées et là vraiment vous
vous introduisez un sujet qui n'existe
pas
parlez-en d'autres
sujets je vous parle de rationalisation
bâtimentaire
aucune formation
si les chiffres que j'ai si les chiffres
que j'ai sont bons madame Dufay sans
parler des lignes de chemin de fer moi
je parle pas de diminuer le service
public sur les frais de fonctionnement
en disant les frais de fonctionnement du
siège de la région socialiste ont été
multipliés par deux et vous le savez
bien donc ça a été dit en séance
plénière ça n'a pas été contesté donc
c'est cela que j'entends par économie
les économies dans la mécanique pas dans
le service public allez s'il vous plaît
il nous reste très peu de temps en guise
de conclusion est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire allez en quelques secondes 45
secondes chacun par exemple quel type de
gouvernance vous voulez pour cette
région comment vous voulez gouverner
cette région qu'est-ce qui comment vous
voyez les élus comment do il se
comporter comment vous voyez cette
nouvelle région Bourgogne Franche-Comté
moi je pense qu'il faut faire de la
politique autrement je pense que mais ça
tout le monde le dit oui mais tout le
monde le dit mais enfin dans nos
entreprises j'ai une expérience
d'entreprise depuis 30 ans on le faisait
aux enfants
je vois bien que seul la politique seul
la politique parfois n'a pas évolué
aujourd'hui le pouvoir solitaire c'est
terminé il faut travailler en équipe
avec des communautés il faut que
jusqu'en bas de l'échelle tout le monde
et la communication l'information il
faut travailler ensemble j'allais même
dire même du fait l'heure est tellement
grave pour notre pays pour nos
collectivités pour les finances de la
crise publique moi j'ai essayé
aujourd'hui justement d'être constructif
rassemblons-nous aussi sur des sujets
communs sur des objectifs communs pour
servir notre pays ça aussi c'est faire
de la politique autrement moi je dis pas
que tout ce que fait la gauche est mal
et tout ce qu'on fait nous et bien ayons
tous une bonne volonté travaillons
ensemble pour cette nouvelle région pour
réussir cette fusion et servir nos
concitoyens Christophe précis mais pour
moi là clairement la nouvelle région
elle doit passer les parties ça peut
être une logique partisane mais une
logique pragmatique de terrain de
projets donc c'est bien une région de
projet qu'il faut mettre en place avec
un respect également des territoires on
respecte les territoires on respecte les
hommes et les femmes quel que soit leur
parti politique et c'est comme ça qu'on
peut créer un projet fédérateur pour
l'ensemble des habitants de Bourgogne
concrètement c'est quoi respecter les
territoires me respecter les territoires
c'est encore une nouvelle fois on est
sur le débat de tout à l'heure de ne pas
imposer un dictat venu de la région
des compétences mais elle peut
décentraliser ses pouvoirs on va pas
faire du jacobinisme il y a eu des lois
de décentralisation il y a quelques
années on va pas refaire
une micro centralisation au détriment du
monde rural au détriment des petites
villes au détriment des territoires qui
ont une vie en autonomie si si le
Prud'homme vous aussi vous prenez un peu
une un nouveau style de gouvernance non
pour les conseils régionaux
l'Europe écologie verte je parle en
général
mais comment vous voyez ça comment vous
voyez ça comment vous vous souhaiteriez
que la région soit gérée
au plus près des citoyens déjà enfin
vraiment enfin en tout cas essayer parce
que cette grande région ça va ça va plus
être une un échelon une collectivité
territoriale de proximité alors que
enfin c'est hyper important la proximité
pour pas continuer à
créer une rupture entre l'élu et le
citoyen parce que concrètement comment
fait-on on va sur le terrain déjà le
plus possible les élus régionaux
aujourd'hui sont pas assez sur le
terrain
ils y sont mais on peut continuer et
augmenter la cadence ils sont très peu
connus d'ailleurs mais voilà par exemple
et on explique ce qu'on fait et
puis on essaye de convaincre le citoyen
enfin en tout cas nous qui a
il faut être capable de répondre à
l'urgence climatique par exemple et
mettre en oeuvre la transition
énergétique des territoires mais à tous
les échelles citoyens etc
autrement et je pense pas que vous soyez
le mieux placé pour en parler monsieur
Joyandet
très sincèrement il faut répondre très
simplement plutôt il faut répondre aux
besoins des gens au quotidien moi j'ai
pris le train entre 100 entre Auxerre et
Paris dimanche dernier pour me rendre
sur Paris on était confinés et des gens
qui payaient leur place qui étaient
debout on n'avait pas la clim on avait
chaud c'est pas digne d'un lien entre la
Bourgogne Franche-Comté et Paris voilà
c'est ça qu'il faut faire il faut
répondre aux besoins des gens au
quotidien voilà c'est tout j'ai rien
d'autre à dire le reste c'est de la
petite discussion et pour l'organisation
du conseil régional lui-même
organisation c'est que les élus vont
être tellement éloignés puis un moment
il va falloir avoir un peu de proximité
et si on n'a pas une merci quand même
non mais il faut une diversité là déjà
c'est conseil régionaux ils servent à
placer des copains qui ont pu demander
locaux c'est la réalité quand même faut
pas l'oublier ou à placer des amis qui
serviront ensuite et qui pourront se
positionner dans certaines villes pour
les prendre c'est ce qui s'est passé aux
dernières élections municipales si on
regarde bien moi je pense que là il faut
faire respirer un petit peu ses
assemblées et c'est pour ça que si les
gens votent pour nous étant donné de ces
inscritant la proportionnelle plus votre
rond pour nous plus on fera des voies
plus on aura des élus allez voilà c'est
mathématiques et c'est tout l'enjeu de
mon combat le mot de la fin pour la
présidente sortante donc moi je l'ai dit
tout au long de la concertation que j'ai
organisé cet automne la Grande Région
devra s'accompagner d'un mouvement de
déconcentration pour que nous puissions
travailler ou plus près avec les
territoires mais il faut que les
territoires se mettent en mouvement
aussi je donne un exemple moi j'attends
que l'air le pôle métropolitain de l'air
urbaine du Nord Franche-Comté mais se
mettent rapidement en place parce que
nous avons besoin et nous aurons besoin
de ces interlocuteurs pour justement
aller repérer au plus près les init qui
permettent le développement de la région
et de la grandeur
vous imaginez des hôtels de Région dans
la préfecture de département par exemple
pas du tout aujourd'hui nous avons un
seul secteur qui est déconcentré au
niveau de nos compétences et le secteur
de la formation vous ne savez peut-être
pas mais c'est notre façon de nous
organiser les politiques de formation ne
sont pas mises en place depuis Besançon
elles sont mises en place au niveau des
5 ou 6 grands bassins d'emploi de la
région demain il nous faudra faire
pareil pour tous nos grands secteurs de
compétences rééquilibrer les territoires
c'est une belle lourdeur administrative
merci merci à tous d'avoir accepté notre
invitation c'est déjà la fin de cette
émission spéciale merci aussi à la Rodia
la salle de musique actuelle de nous
avoir accueilli sur sa terrasse
aujourd'hui à Besançon ces beaux
Besançon c'est presque aussi
à tous profitez bien de votre week-end
et puis on se retrouve régulièrement on
va suivre la campagne dans vos sur vos
chaînes régionales on ne vous entend
plus Marie Guy dupé vous ne prenez pas
votre micro bon week à tous